advertisers threaten boycott if Trump
reinstated to Twitter clients from Ad
Agency that spend 60 billion dollars per
year in media spending will pause all ad
purchases if Trump's account returns why
why are advertisers saying we don't want
Trump on the platform what do these
things have to do with each other other
than these are ESG companies it's
politically motivated Elon Musk needs to
recognize this but it seems like he's
he's bowing to it well these are what do
you call impact investors and they're
willing to throw money at political
causes they want to see someone other
than Donald Trump be elected the nice
thing about owning this company and
making it private is that he doesn't
when you have a public company yeah you
have not only do you have shareholders
then you even the public private company
that you have that you co-own with
someone else like in the case of Mines
Bill and John ran it together they each
own half it was hard to get stuff done
because if Bill wanted to do something
it had to go through John and if John
didn't want to do it it didn't happen so
I imagine at Twitter there's like six
guys all with veto power impossible like
you said it took a year to get an edit
button right through now you got one
owner he says yes it gets done right
it's the power of the dictator there's
also a global corporate collusion with
Bankers happening under the name of the
ESG and I think this has a lot to do
with it because if they can have
companies literally jumping whenever the
bankers want them to jump uh singing
whenever the bankers want them to sing
doing whatever the bankers want them to
do under this social credit score this
corporate social credit score this is
another element of it that we have to
understand here this is a coordinated
effort by a lot of very powerful people
Bill Gates being one of them putting all
of his money into institutions saying
hey hurt Twitter now Twitter is a threat
against me my Empire my money right now
people are going to be able to talk and
find out all the lies that I told them
people are going to find out all the
horrible things I did to them red alert
right now we need to shut Twitter down
get all the advertisers and again Elon
Musk has actually addressed this he
talked about doing a subscriber based
model he talked about changing the
financial aspects of of Twitter so so he
sees this this attack coming as well but
we gotta understand here there's very
powerful people right now that are going
to be looking at Twitter as a direct
threat against their hegemony on the
narrative on the conversation on the
truth that's the Brutus metaphor of what
you're saying earlier the longer Elon
holds this hot potato the more of a
Target he becomes so he needs to release
come out forceful make these radical
changes and overwhelm them which is what
the left does when they're in power you
can make a comparison when Trump was in
his office for the first four years he
he dithered he dallied he could have
done a lot more things until he waited
to the last few months which was sad but
you make a good point from previously it
really goes back to if you build it they
will come they could have this hissy fit
they can pull out their money but if
he's truly going to turn this into a new
revolutionary platform move it away from
this Advertiser beholden structure into
something more we chat better Tech
better features and the masses come back
to Twitter what are they going to do
they're not going to be able to hold off
for long because they're missing a
massive Market uh for for potential
advertising you know Supply so they're
not going to turn that down someone's
super it's me super chatted Elon needs
to charge five dollars to tweet at Trump
only make the rest ad free one trillion
a year profit all the Trump reply guys
is like well if you tweet at Trump it's
five dollars and then they would just
fund the whole the whole platform that's
it that's how you monetize it there you
go it's as simple as that huh I asked
Bill ottman if he wanted to Federate
Minds with Twitter parlor Rumble and
Truth social and he was like hell yeah
except not the fediverse because of the
limitations and it was just a vague
interaction we had but he pointed at
Noster which I mentioned at the
beginning of the show n-o-s-t-r it's a
it's a protocol
um let's see you can go to Noster it's
on github.com Noster Dash protocol uh so
I think what's gonna happen is all these
networks are going to be able to
interoperate like you'll be able to see
truth social content while you're logged
in because the problem with the feta
versus it doesn't have a universal login
it's going to aggregate everything yeah
yeah with Federal you'd have to log into
like Mastodon to view everything that's
Federated and if Mastodon wants you
banned you can't view anything anymore
because you're Mastodon account I can't
write off All Tech because all Tech
definitely pushed Twitter and obviously
he's pushing Elon it's led to a lot of
the tech features they've begun to
release so it's done its job I hope
elon's you know revolution of Twitter
doesn't totally you know negate
everything that you guys are building
and others are building we can take it
offline too like we could have web mesh
networks locally with this software with
this Twitter and Minds all this stuff
we're like I can tweet at you if you're
nearby without having any kind of
Internet just on our devices it look I
think Elon rights to communicate much
more and much more quickly because I do
not see any logic or Reason Why certain
accounts like the Babylon b haven't been
reinstated more importantly uh James
Lindsay he got banned for calling
someone a groomer who was you know is he
literally a groomer he's not insulting
lgbtq people he's literally targeting he
was calling out somebody who was
grooming kids he was banned for that
there are many things that Elon could
have walked in and snapped his fingers
if his complaint is that it took him a
year to make an edit button then it's
like okay I get it we're on we're on day
one and a half or whatever but that's
why communication is important cat turd
tweeted
it's it's elon's taking over nothing's
changed Eon said I'll be digging into
this more today then he comes out and
says we won't do anything anything until
our committee happens
are you kidding okay dude look I feel
like it's it's
if Elon doesn't immediately just pull
out the lightning bolt of Zeus and throw
it he's going to keep sitting down
having conversations like Dorsey I'll
put it this way
the old Trope about the president
getting elected and you know he's on the
campaign Trail saying I'm going to end
the wars and I'm going to get the price
of gas down then he gets into office the
CIA the FBI DHS they all slam all these
photos in his desk and say you can't and
here's why and then instead of pulling a
trump where Trump goes excuse me excuse
me I don't know I don't care get this
out of here I'm doing what I want we're
getting the troops out and then they all
lost their mind and tried to get rid of
him elon's going in there and and I
worry and I don't know it's only been
day one but he may go in and pull a
traditional presidential Trope in that
he goes I'm gonna unban everybody and
I'm gonna do these things he sits down
and they go okay now this Advertiser
does 300 million per year they said that
if Trump is on the platform they won't
advertise it anymore if you don't have
that money we lose this core of the
company and then this company says we
don't like Milo they complained if you
have him on and then elon's gonna go
okay so
if I have these 10 people banned we keep
all this money and the platform keeps
working all right well I guess I'll
compromise there I had a conversation
with the tech CEO a long time ago of a
big big social media platform and they
told me
it's a guy and he said Tim
I don't want to ban these people but if
I don't ban this guy
everyone loses the platform so what am I
supposed to do and I was like I don't
know grow a pair of balls call the bluff
of these companies look them in the eye
and say if you don't want to advertise
on the platform that everyone is on and
you want to make yourself irrelevant by
all means Will Wheaton is hanging out
who knows where these days he's on
Twitter or on Mastodon but I'm sure he
look he's looking for someone to talk to
you can go hang out with them if you
want to be in our house where the party
is at then you accept there are people
here who say things you don't like if
Elon doesn't just assert that
immediately we're spiraling back into
the same problem right the fact that
he's saying we need a diverse board to
decide this I'm not like there we go
again I heard the same thing from Dorsey
three years ago and Elon saying the same
thing again I said it was a bad move I
stand by and I like how he's obviously
being very responsive and the Twitter
replies but Jack was the same and
exactly he went on Rogan he did all the
song and dance and nothing changed so
he's going to repeat history and it's
going to lead to the down the continued
downfall of Twitter and again it goes
back to Trump but what do you have to
lose but this is why the the Twitter
exec's cashed out right they were like
all right it's all yours buddy yeah
enjoy I have hope well we'll see you
different because let time tell yeah but
it's still early on here when Jack was
involved it was a public company and he
didn't have control of it at that point
anymore he was just kind of saying what
he wanted but Elon has full control at
this point I mean which means there's no
FBI and the things like that right legal
he can't do illegal things obviously but
he's got right he's got the reins and
he's got his foot on the gas the stakes
are so high we have to hold his his feet
to the fire to the coals just that the
stakes couldn't be higher this is a
civilizational type of thing we're
dealing with this is the Public Square
this is the means of communication the
the way to disseminate any kind of idea
so it's not just any other business it's
not a retail operation it's not a car
company it it's really goes beyond that
maybe not on the financial side but
certainly on the civilizational side
here's here's what's gonna happen he's
convening this this diverse Viewpoint
moderation ecumenical council and here's
what's going to happen if he does have
progressives on it they're going to say
Do not reinstate Alex Jones he's a
violent authoritarian fascist bigot Elon
is going to tell going to have to tell
them to screw off or he's going to have
to listen to them
either way what's the point of doing the
counsel
if you got to tell him to screw off
anyway because you know what their
answer is going to be then uh just unban
Jones if you are not going to then
you're just listening to the Mob there's
there's no middle ground here there's no
magical world where the people who have
been who burned down cities for in the
George Floyd rise and then lie about in
the media there's no world where they
are like peacefully negotiating with you
because the left governs in the private
sector in the public sector by their
ideology and their ideology will dictate
their actions and then you have you know
good intention people like Elon coming
into and they're like you know we'll
make a committee we'll make a council
let's let everyone hear it out and it
doesn't go anywhere I'll I'll take the
win for now I don't want to be you know
total Negative Nancy on this one it's
been good I'm just genuinely confused as
to why he didn't unban The Babylon bee
immediately it would have been big press
it would have been good I can imagine a
few things
the reason why Twitter bans the people
they do is because advertisers demand it
that's it because the left is good at
organizing they don't just send
complaints themselves they complained to
they complained to advertisers and say
we will come for you these advertisers
know yeah they mean it they'll come with
firebombs bricks signs they'll cause us
damage they'll smash the windows out
let me tell you if you own a storefront
in Portland
well I'll say Berkeley all the Berkeley
storefronts have anti-trump or they did
not like and woke signs why
if in the middle of night someone throws
a brick what can you do call the police
you and the police are going to say
they're going to say sorry it happened
to you let us know if anything else
happens see ya what are they gonna do
they're going to launch a big
investigation to hunt down a person who
ran by with a rock never gonna happen
but you're going to pay thousands of
dollars or however much to fix that
gigantic window so then everyone just
says it's easier just to put the sign up
and mind my own business and this is
what happens with big corporations let's
say you sell Saudi pop and then you get
50 emails from antifa from BLM and they
say we can cause you so much damage you
will regret Crossing us and they go I
don't care about this just fine we'll
we'll stop advertising on Twitter it
doesn't make enough money for us anyway
then Elon or whoever's at Twitter sees
that come in look we're getting tons of
complaints about Milo we don't want to
advertise in your platform anymore and
they go look either we ban Milo or we
lose the whole platform and then they do
and that's the chain of events unless
someone is willing to say it's either
this or nothing it will not change I
mean that didn't happen yet if it does
he deserves to be called out right I'm a
little bit more optimistic we're still
early let time tell time what what do
you mean we we it's been seven months we
all know the Babylon B is unfairly
locked up lock locked out of there yeah
there's an election in a week
and Elon Musk finally secures the
platform and if anything he could do is
say my friends The Babylon B shouldn't
have been banned I already know that's
true I am going to remove this lock as
for other people I don't know I am going
to need some time to work through this
I'd accept that and the counter argument
to which you just stated before is that
the Twitter has been thoroughly wobified
for years and it's an unprofitable dying
platform it's been continuously making
bad mistakes on the tech front it's
losing users most of its users are Bots
they've tried the fully woke model and
it's not working from a financial
perspective so if he's going to be
intimidated by the supposed Financial
repercussions of allowing more free
speech on Banning The Babylon B I think
is back oh maybe go on Twitter right now
I think they're back I just he's
watching I think Babylon B is back right
now I haven't seen any tweets I just
looked at it a minute ago and it's just
it's just like uh they're not back it
was locked so they weren't like the
account wasn't erased or anything it was
just locked until they
they can't get access to their account
to view or post tweets until they remove
the offensive tweet on Rachel Levine so
this is what keeps happening so which is
like literally like so many tactic that
they do regret take it back take it back
now you've been a bad boy I get dozens
of messages every day from people who
are like Tim
is back and I'm like oh
as they assume that Trump's account
shouldn't exist it's like no on
Instagram he can't post anything on
Facebook his account is there people
think because they can see it it means
they're back so I hear this non-stop
every single time I I look I I made my
point
um Elon waiting on this I know it's been
a day so okay I don't know I'll calm
down a little bit we'll see we'll see
over the week if we're gonna get any any
any
um meaningful changes
I I just I I really need
I think I don't understand why why we
didn't see anything the move is to do it
all at once and you say in a sweeping
move all accounts that have been banned
or or locked that didn't violate U.S
state law are hereby reinstated agreed
yeah and he couldn't he could do that
today right and probably take the
weekend to do it and then on Monday
morning or or but he'll do it he'll do
it 4 20 on Sunday and again but it's so
much harder for them to respond the
concern is that big advertisers like
this one are saying will pull our ads
and if there's no money coming in
there's no Twitter but unless someone
breaks the addiction cycle of this
broken psychotic machine it will keep
happening what's Twitter blue you know
how much money they're pulling in from
Twitter it's like three bucks a month
but here's the issue you want to know
why antifa is allowed to organize
illegal activity on the platform and get
away with it because Twitter is scared
of them because the big advertisers are
scared of them that's why they don't get
banned because they're the look I say it
all the time does Twitter headquarters
pre-elon were they ever scared that like
Dave Rubin is going to lead a bunch of
classic liberals with pitchforks and
torches to their doorstep no are they
concerned a bunch of black masked
lunatic Psychopaths with bricks and
molotovs and guns would yeah because
they do so Twitter Facebook YouTube
Every Advertiser they are scared to
death that one day they'll walk outside
their building and some guy will hit him
in the face with a brick and it's not
going to be a conservative so we can ban
the conservatives because they won't do
anything about it anyway but we better
not cross anti-fun the extremist left
it's still happening right now and
you're presenting a broader political
dilemma is that it's this asymmetrical
political fight where the conservatives
are the right wing are fighting with
their hands tied behind their back and
the left wing are bringing guns to a
knife fighter not even to a fight at all
and they're just playing to win they
don't care about the substance they
don't care about the style they don't
care about anything else they're there
for one thing one thing only power power
dynamics and advancing their ideology
and they don't care about any of the
nice cities associated with you know
councils Etc I would not be surprised
okay look
it's a victory that Elon bought the
platform we cracked the Louis 13th I
know I know I know but I'm I'm just I'm
eager to make sure this goes in the
right direction and his his announcement
about some some diverse Viewpoint
counsel sounds just like Jack Dorsey
just like Vijaya got it sounds exactly
like what they were saying based on that
I wouldn't be surprised I'm not saying
it's highly probable if come April there
is uh you know me sitting with Elon and
Joe being like Elon why won't you do
this we had this antifa person and
neon's gonna be like you know we're
going in and we're trying to make sure
we're doing it fair blah blah blah blah
I'm not saying it's highly probable I'm
not saying I would bet on that I'm
saying I wouldn't be surprised based on
wanting a diverse Viewpoint committee or
whatever I'm like that right there was
just like oh that's more BS start a
crypto token start a utility token Elon
a Twitter token what if he puts Doge on
Twitter yeah use Doge and then you can
pay users with dogecoins so here's
here's another strange phenomenon we can
talk about uh here's my social blade for
my my Twitter account look at me with
one million 361 000 followers thank you
for following me I I just tweet nonsense
I've lost 5 000 so far this month but
that's up 22 and and probably because
I've been you know I just tweet kind of
stupid nonsense but uh today
I gained 4264 followers what about you
Luke you gained a bunch of followers I I
did and a whole bunch of Engagement a
whole bunch of likes that I never had
before I'm gonna check right now and so
probably maybe they have started with
the lower level accounts and they're
working their way up and these are some
of the well he's you know he said he's
not he didn't make any changes yeah he
said no changes have happened thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there